in that moment
elvis the man was sacrificed
and elvis the god was born
you're looking for trouble
you came to the right place
first of all everyone congratulations on
the film austin i want to start with you
because as a comic book head i'm not
gonna lie i just adored seeing the
captain marvel in the trailer and i know
that's you know vaz put it in there but
elvis was kind of a superhero and i
think that's what this film is going to
bring to that was that something that
you really wanted to bring into this
because he really was larger than life
he really was larger than life and that
that's uh
yeah he
watching it the other night i it felt
like a superhero yeah
even the way the music would soar these
moments that felt super human
yeah completely and he was so inspired
in his youth by comic books
and uh and you know him being raised
incredibly poor and and feeling this
this desire for the ability to be able
to take care of his parents and and to
break out of that and live the life of
two people being a twinless twin there's
so many uh aspects of that but
but it's the tricky thing is is that if
you just look at that you only see the
superhero yeah and you don't see the
human behind it and so for me it was
there are those moments of which we get
to see in the film of the superhero
elvis but it's stripping that away and
seeing how he is on a day-to-day basis
and the vulnerability and the
sensitivity that he had that was what
was so fascinating to me yeah and i'm
not going to say obviously his music and
his talent was a superhero but if he had
a cape i would have to say it was his
sex appeal and i'm sorry awesome i'm
going to put this one to baz because he
definitely he framed you very nicely
with that camera and i think you made a
conscious effort i think because i don't
think people realize that was the first
time sex got really broadcast into
american homes
there's a moment in the movie where you
guys really center in on that talk about
how you wanted to bring
elvis to the young generation and get
these kids that are used to like
tick-tock and only fans to understand
you don't understand this is the first
time yeah yeah first time's the thing
and look look it's really important i
mean the film really is about american
50s 60s and 70s
culture and race you know i would say no
issue of race
no elvis yeah because he's born you know
he's for a time he spends time in this
one
white designated house during
segregation black community i mean i did
all this work i met the people like god
the story i only tell the story but what
it does do with him i think is
he's always they're always running
longing and he's absorbing things so
when it comes to his sexuality it's the
rebellion i mean it was dangerous to be
having black friends and being on beale
street you know only one white kid in
beale street was dangerous and he's a
rebel but when it comes to his appeal
he made it up like style it took style
the side burns you know from a truck
driver you know he was broke up yeah i
think i think he's got this thing it's
such a chemical thing you see it in
harry styles you know he's got a bit of
a fluidity to him well that's where i
was going oh sorry
i'm used to my house
nobody does he like before people saying
fluid style he was wearing really always
masculine with his like
you know lace tank tops tied up like you
just like no man in the south would
dress like that to take a line that is
actually said by another person but it's
real in the movie i cannot overstate how
strange he looked that was actually said
historically when he was standing on
stage and what's so crazy coming from
the black culture is like that preening
that like flamboyance that's what he was
borrowing from it was so crazy to see it
and then to see how it beguiled the
world and i think one of the best people
at beguiled was obviously
you know what i mean and obviously just
took her essentially from that place of
just you know keptness of being growing
up in a military base i was a military
kid and i did that what was it like
talking to brazil about that because i
can only imagine what it was like for
her to be so sheltered and then get to
thrown into the spotlight and then
everything that happened now absolutely
i mean we unfortunately during the
shooting didn't get to touch base just
you know with covert and it was tricky
um we haven't uh delved into the details
of her her life specifically but to read
her book and to do the research that i
did and to
lean into um those experiences obviously
like with with empathy and knowledge and
talking to you guys about it as well
because baz and arsene know everything
about everything to do with elvis a
wealth of knowledge um it was really
fascinating it was such a different time
i think like baz says this movie is so
much
as much about elvis as it is about
america in the 50s 60s and 70s and so to
lean into that time period and what it
was like for a young girl at that time
what it was like for women the fact you
know they were both in germany when they
met it was the middle of world war ii
they were isolated you know she didn't
have many friends to lean into that was
really really fascinating and to sort of
step into how that relationship then
blossomed
um from that place and where it led them
um was beautiful and it was uh i loved
being able to do that with with us yeah
yeah i mean you both had to i think fine
there's always i think a trepidation
when you're playing a real person and
there's i think an aspect of finding the
character that every actor has to go
through from what you research to what's
on the page and then the the sort of
gray in between and i think every actor
i talk to when they do this they say
there's a moment when it stopped being
elvis and it just became the guy that
you were playing or the girl that you
were playing so what was that moment for
you austin i'd like to hear what that
moment was for you when they stopped
being again a character and they felt
like somebody you could really live in
was it when you put on the clothes was
it the first time you sang one of the
songs
there's
a ton of these transitional moments in
the process where you start to feel
keys of authenticity
and
for me the the most significant one was
the first performance
i was absolutely terrified and the first
performance we did was 68. oh wow i
remember i'm doing the 60th special it's
our second day of filming
such a special day the movie almost went
away
and at this point there's a year and a
half that i've had to prepare and
suddenly here's a moment of truth i've
got to walk out on stage in the black in
front of so many people in front of like
hundreds of people
300 people yeah there's tons of people
and uh
i i was in the dressing room beforehand
i felt my hands shaking and i felt this
terror inside of me and i'd been living
with this for so long but i had this
moment of thinking can i do it am i a
fraud am i gonna fall flat on my face am
i gonna let baz down am i gonna let the
film down what happens if that happens
and my mind started to go
and then
it dawned on me
that
this is a make-or-break moment in my
career but it was a make-or-break moment
in elvis's career
everything was writing and also you fed
so much off the audience too like being
able to have that i mean i don't want to
speak for you but i could you could tell
just watching it like
feeding off of the audience and that
audience's energy is so nice
channeling that yeah
once you go once once i realized it's
not a bad thing for me to feel this this
is what he was feeling this is what he
felt like on the inside so now as i walk
out there he would be feeling this so i
can rest in that and instead it's how i
how i direct this energy and so that
became about building rapport with the
audience and it was when i started to
see genuine emotion on their faces yeah
when i saw a girl blush and i saw one
laugh and i saw a truth then suddenly i
looked down and i see the leather and i
realized this is the closest that
anybody has ever felt too elvis in that
moment
can i just say from watching from the
outside i remember i was sitting up the
back and i was sitting next to luke
brazy and we both were like kind of like
oh yeah like we're going to see how this
is going to go how's it going
and i remember from the second you
walked out because you we were from
behind so we just saw the back a it was
like watching the real thing but b to
watch the past and the present come
together through austin and through the
eyes of baz was just it was one of those
moments where during the pandemic
everything was so crazy but for the
first moment everyone in the room was
present everyone in the room was
together and like
looking and experiencing the same thing
and i'll never forget that i gotta add
one more thing that in that play down
there when we screen the movie at the
end of that sequence
excuse me and i've been
here four times
that is a dry audience you know at the
end of that performance in the leather
they broke into spontaneous loud
applause and austin had never seen a
film he saw it the first time that night
and tom had seen it and tom leaned
across and went like this
in the dark
but the crowd applauded as if they were
at a rock concert and that was the
moment when i went like i we wanted to
make a theatrical film a film to be in
the theaters for people to come back and
give them a reason to come back to the
theater that was a theatrical reaction
no it was absolutely and that's what you
can't fake in any other setting like you
felt it it was electric and i think it
was because like for me especially like
i grew up my dad was a huge elvis fan
huge rhythm of blues fan but the
marriage of the modern elements is
really what i think is going to let
folks that maybe didn't know anything
about elvis just get so into it and you
were very i think deliberate in some of
the acts you bought like casey musgraves
doji cat um but also like even at the
after party last night man skin and all
of these folks sort of coming together
to show elvis's influence in modern but
also where it borrowed from so how did
you make those choices because you kind
of have everybody to choose yeah like
look it's a really simple thing like
bacon i've done all my time but let's go
back to gatsby i mean jazz back then was
this visceral black street music that
that and really edgy that fitzgerald
puts in the book and people say why you
putting that music in there it's going
to be a fad it'll go away and he puts it
in there and
it's the jazz age
now with elvis is like when you go to
beale street and big mama thornton is
singing you know hound dog what she's
really saying is listen expletive don't
go running around expletive and come
back here expecting expletive expletive
the road jack
just like that yeah but the language
that she's singing is charming yeah
another mother hound
like any young person's gonna go is it
about a dog i don't know right doger cat
we start with shankar who was that's a
whole other story brilliant singing
gospel in the churches we're recording
in would you like to come and play big
mom of the horn yeah blessings would you
like to come and do a record with jojo
cat blessings would you like to come to
coachella and can't have a giant silver
robot blessing you want to be in a clip
with you know doji cat coming soon
blessings
right but but she trans she's not big
mom of thornton dodger cat she's
translating the language so that a
younger person gets what big mamathorn's
singing about so it's the same device
and i don't do it a lot there's a lot of
classic elvis austin sings the young
elvis there's real elvis but there is
this translation device so that you not
only understand what it was but more
importantly what did it feel like yeah
and i'm glad you brought up the voice
because that was the part that sort of
blew me away because a lot of the
footage that folks have seen already is
the very early elvis from the
performances that's in the trailer it's
what we got to see at cinemacon it's
literally what has lit everyone up from
the minute they've seen this film was
coming and then when i found out that
that was you singing i like kind of lost
it a little bit more because i know
we've had a lot of recent sort of
biopics of similar elk but not every one
of them does that i will just say that
even you know the ones where they are
singing they're maybe doing it in a
magical realism sort of way you
literally had to give that performance
so the voice both this the
the speaking voice the idiolic that you
had to do but also the voice that you
had to sing in because it's just so any
wrong note that it can be
snl right yeah yeah that's that was
i'll tell you that's one of the things
that woke me up every day at three in
the morning i couldn't go back to sleep
because
it was this feeling of i don't want to
let this down and uh
so i would i'd start listening to
interviews first thing in the morning
with him talking to you talk to myself
you saw me do that
i i'd walk down the beach for four hours
just listening to an elvis interview and
speaking out loud and ineligible yeah
looking like i i i was a complete wild
man
and we're on the gold coast australia
very very australian and then i wanted
to feel what it feels like
in everyday life you know so that way it
doesn't feel like i'm having to make a
big transition from
me to
elvis and and so
as much as i can start merging those
things and feel like that's the voice i
speak in the morning when i wake up
that's the voice i speak in after i
brush my teeth i remember that's what i
found when we were doing scenes together
that was so easy about it because
oftentimes i think you can feel like
because the voice is such a specific
thing that's it's fake or like you're
not really acting with anybody but it
was there was an ease when we did our
scenes because it was so lived in
the voice was so lived in and natural
and authentic that the bounce back and
forth just felt
normal yeah you weren't bouncing up
against this like
yeah
or even the lack of voice because one of
the things i think austin and this was
not direction this was his meticulous
when priscilla who i spoke to very early
on lost contact with was a little bit
understandably skeptical could austin
what what are they going to do with my
husband
but when she saw the movie the thing she
said is she's surrounded by
impersonators you know and they good on
them it's a competition you know but for
her it's uncomfortable sometimes you
know and she said
the thing is that
yeah every wink every move all of that
but the spirit that the actual soul of
the guy you know the humanity and the
anger actually that was cool he got his
anger you know and and that was amazing
but you know what also got to give you
props here
i didn't direct him to do this but
something he picked up from elvis was
the lack of words so when the colonel
does that scene where he goes well i
will leave you austin just goes i'm bat
my bad version
hmm
and this was a thing he had going on so
elvis
no words well i didn't say that when i
haven't told you guys this but i was
sitting next to priscilla at the
screening at khan which was no pressure
it's insane but he she turned to me at
one point and was like man like he
really has him he really has him down to
a tee but he really does have it doesn't
it
i know everyone's asking you this song
and i think if you're a real elvis fan
it's like choosing between your children
on which was your favorite of his songs
but i do know after filming this you
probably have an emotional attachment to
one of the performances or one of the
songs or one of the songs that is maybe
even played like i love the little dolly
parton easter egg with i will always
love you because you have to be like a
really big deep like elvis had to know
that one so what is oh yeah you you
really you really are yeah
yeah we actually
sang it in the car yeah and but we just
couldn't do two exactly
i know darling she was so keen she tells
the most beautiful story about her
wanting elvis to do it and she sat down
and she said i've got no disrespect for
the colonel he was a smart man too i
mean i said colonel this is my legacy
for my children you know i just love
them oh i love that so much
you